foreign
we talked about Connor McDavid and his Art Ross
trophies home to Rick seitel he's out there to
start this game the last four years he's about
one Art Ross two Runners up and a fourth they
are Dynamic players to be sure and they're into
the Vancouver zone right away that David feeds the
blue line there's a bouncing shot that just went
wide to the goal puck winds up in the corner back
to Smith for the Canucks to our left Stuart
Skinner to our right stand underway in the second
between these two Pacific Division rivals Oilers
won the season series last year connects one one
and two against him they only met three times
they'll play four in the regular season this year
Darnell nurse turning out of his own Zone
Evan Bouchard ahead to Evander King pass
through good room to Connor Brown and hooks
one back came wedged out over top of the goal
now mcdaven checked by kuznenko and he'll
try to pass back in his own Zone that didn't
work Oilers steal the puck back and they
go to work Kane across McDavid couldn't
make contact now a shot by nurse is off the
Stick of hoglander dry saddle took exception
[Applause]
fourth power play for the Canucks looking
to break this scoreless deadlock Puck Center
knocked away from Garland Hughes able
to keep it in long race shot didn't get
through Garland after the rebound Puck cleared
off the boards and out to Center [Applause]
brought back in by Patterson here's Hughes
moving down for the right Point watched by Yanmar
now kuzmenko back to Queen Hughes
let's go over the restaurant
[Music]
Conor Garland in front got a piece of that one
I think and the Canucks on the power play have
opened the scoring at the passing Lanes down low
open up but in this case is able to pull it into
the middle might have hit Bouchard not Garland
who is reaching to tip it it's huge goal I think
isn't it Evan Bouchard in front [Applause]
shots in the period six to three in favor
of the Oilers so not a lot going on at either
Canucks with the power play goal from Hughes
here's Hyman hockey Center good position there
from games to knock it away the pass intended
for Ryan agent Hopkins all right Canucks Pederson
stole the puck for a moment Oilers get it back
keeping away from games but now he gives it
away to Andre kuzmenko he's into the evidence
Zone puts the puck between the legs Cuts in
front stopped by Skinner you want to move by
kuzmenko off the left wing but he just couldn't
get it over the shoulder of the goaltender Oilers
three on two the other way Bouchard shoots
blocked up right up the middle Newton Hopkins
gets it takes it to the side passes around
for dry sandals centering passengers scores
foreign
Hopkins is unchecked former pupil at Suncrest
Elementary and he ties to score here 1-1
so I'm in at 46 of penalty killing time in the
opening period as the Oilers went oh for two
power plays favorite cops five to two in this game
Vancouver's only goal came with a man advantage
[Applause]
all the way down 24 seconds
looking for the drop pass Luger stole it
and he's trying to get loose Teddy blucher
pursued my Bouchard gets him in the back
and Skinner's got it underneath his pads
with Luger trying to get the Lakes going
Shield the puck to get a shot sometimes I
like to try to draw the penalty but just stuck
under the right pad it's pretty sneaky Sean oh
they hold one-hander [Music] and Skinner kneels
Oman in on the porch pokes the [__] around
giving away by Dave Harney here's Danika and
he's shot it just wide he might have caught
a piece of the golden now for the giveaway
by the owners instead Nika had a good chance
Oma keeps the puck in with the glove now
bluger it's his turn to keep it in the
zone but the Oilers take the puck away and
they'll bring it ahead lead pass Kane steps
in on the right way Commander Kane with a hard
Slap Shot and he wired that one off the glass
shot from the other side sails wide King
gets it again backs to Philip Kemp [Applause]
it's for McDavid lost the handle Myers couldn't
clear it outside the line but now they have a
chance to move it out and blogger just
flips the [__] side on her territory
lots of continuous action here in the second
and his Lane Peterson's in with a wrist shot
knocked down by the Smith [Applause] six and
a half minutes into the middle frame a 1-1 tie
Clinton Hughes [Applause] his makeup high
with that attempted chip onto the left
handerson shoots the pocket connects her
offside here they'll tag up and play will
continue players in the preseason like this
style of hockey just keep going no whistles
here's Derek Ryan and who shot with a shot
blocked by Hoagland and he tripped Bouchard
to the Blue Line no call and it connects with
a three-on-one Henderson in Elias Henderson
fans didn't like that no call his blue shot
went under the Gown under the check of Neil's
homelander and the Canucks had three the other
way kind of used his legs to get some language
no chance at the other end in a backhander
went wide that was Adam already trying to put
the Oilers on top now Sushi breaks things
up and he brings the bucket in [Applause]
[Music]
by the Oilers big ones now McDavid Into the Blue
Line nurse right Point Bouchard 20 seconds to go
in the third period nurse shoots that was tipped
with McDavid coming from below the goal line got a
piece of an l-ny [Applause] fights off the check
of Connor Brown and plays the pocket under 10
seconds remaining in regulation as nurse sends the
puck ahead and down and that's gonna do it this
game will go to overtime tied at one both goals
came in the second period Hughes on a power plant
and Patterson strong Face-Off night continues as
he gives the Canucks first possession in overtime
again three overtime goals in the regular season
last year for Peterson museum with a rich shot
that kicked off the older player went wide in
the goal Hughes brings the puck back [Applause]
here's Connor Garland in over the blue
line find some room on the left side
Quinn Hughes to the backhand lets it go that
might have hit Patterson in front and the
owners get their first possession of Overton
it's even a change both forwards Hughes still
out there as dry said on the museum out to
near side dishes across broken up blue shark
will bring the puck out to seven the Hughes
going to try to get to the bench no he's not
he's going to try to defend but David's
behind him he's in he beats the storms
all right